hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the Alta box
Norway championship it's round six its
Magnus Carlsen with the white pieces
against the ding Liron so a very
interesting matchup for world number one
against world number three and it's very
interesting in there I think 11 past
classical matchups all 11 games ended in
a draw now I will not tell you as usual
if this is a again from the classical
time format or from the Armageddon but
you will you know just enjoy the game
and then have to decide for ourselves
although I will mention it you know in
the end so without further ado let's
just check it out cross on wood white
pieces opens with E for with E 5 biding
Knight to f3 knight c6 and Bishop to b5
and I would just like to say that some
of you have mentioned that the previous
photo of thing that we've used as you
know the profile photo of the player on
the Left wasn't all that great so I
improved it with this one again courtesy
of lunar tortoise official photographer
of the autumn of snowy championship you
know very nice photo both of them
smiling so I hope it's all better now
and we have a 6 biding the morphe
defense Bishop to a4 and Knight to f6
with d3 and now b5 pushing the bush back
Bishop to b3 and Bishop to see finals c5
biding we have c3 by Carson
we have d6 by dink and now Bishop to g5
and here we have a very interesting
maneuver biding h6 Bishop to h4 and now
g5 so dink decided to attack both on the
Queen side and on the Kings side most
most interesting we have Bishop to g3
and now Bishop back to b6 making room
for the c5 pawn after the knight moves
to a5 now with that Knight B to d2 by
cross and preparing the castle then of
course you want to go rook e1 9f 193 and
the knight and III will be a very nice
piece with nice day 5 biding harassing
the bishop here brush up the c2 and now
again a very cool move wedding-night to
h5 now you all have heard the old saying
the knight on the rim is grim but what
about two knights on you know each on
their own Rim
maybe maybe things onto something here
you know
no no book ever covered her what about
if you have two knights on the rim but
you know we'll just see what
once across and pushes a for a nice
flank attack on the queenside and here
there are two games one that continued
Bishop to d7 one that continued castles
in the database but dingos rook to b8
and it is a new move so as a more
thirteen we have a completely new game
we have b4 by cross and continues
expanding on the Queen side and now
first ding captures on g3 a nice
in-between move H captures and g3 and
now only now Knight back to c6 and here
cousin continues with his plan I to f1
the knight not wants to go to e3 we have
Queen to f6 biding and now Quinta e to
buy cousin may be preparing to Castle
queenside who knows
we have Knight to e7 biding preparing to
go to g6 which will be a very nice
square and now Knight to e3 and now the
night is very nice here are controlling
the d5 and DF v square we have h5 by
ding now saying that maybe he just wants
to continue attack maybe he's not even
planning the castle and Bishop to b3 the
bishop is much more useful on this long
diagonal of course and c6 biding with a
capture Sun b-58 capture some b5 and now
d4 by Magnus pushing in the center and
it's very interesting both the ding and
cross is still not you know showing
anything where the hell the King will be
in this game so you know very very
exciting
we have g4 biding and here cross and
says well I saw you know your Knights
and the real world very nice so I might
just do that as well we have d captors
and if I first D captures and only not
Knights to h4 and now Magnus does have a
knight on the rim but to both of the
night Knights nicely controlling DF v
square so not really a problem we have
Queen to g5 biding making room for the F
pawn and now crossing just castles and
here after ding saw that cross on castle
Queens King side he castles King side as
well as now he feels much safer there
it's very unlikely that cousin will push
any of the points in front of the king
or will he yes we will have to see about
that
here we have rook 8 2 d1 cousin grabs
hold of this open a file but ding says
well if you don't want the open a file
then I'm just gonna take the open a file
for myself he wants to get as much
activity as possible rook to a3 is the
idea we have kinked the h2 and much
safer square you don't want your King
understand
diagonal as this Bishop occupies here
and our ding just brings the rook into
the game Rooker a3 Carson does not enjoy
all of this activity from dings rook so
he pushes it back we have Quinta b2 rook
goes back to a7 and now a very nice roof
lived by magnus roof to d6 here we have
rook King to g7 biding and now comes c4
by Magnus
we have Bishop to c7 pushing the route
back and here an interesting option for
Magnus was definitely c5 but again it's
hard to decide for such a move after
Bishop captures pawn captures and the
knight moves Knight e5 check now the
bishop can capture 90 checks again King
h7 and now you have this very strong
protected pass pawn on d6 you can
transfer your attention to the C pawn
you can go Queen to c5 you know her as
the rook here on a 7 a lot of
interesting options Magnus doesn't think
it's a thing it you know good good good
enough to play so here Magnus plays f4
and it's really really a crazy move and
I don't know what to make of this move
if some of you are watching the official
stream maybe maybe you've seen the
interview in Norwegian or if you
understand Norwegian you know do do
share with us why Magnus played at 4
it's really a theatre it was just a
blunder or a really deep positional
sacrifice because here dink plays G
captures on f3 on Poisson and Magnus
just returns with the rook rook to d3
ding grabs another pawn with F Catherine
g2 and now kink a person g2 so Magnus
just gave up the two pawns in front of
his King and now he continues to play
positional chess with f6 from dink and
now comes c5 so just you know nicely
grabbing more squares we have looked to
d8 by dink now he wants to of course
trade Magnus trades with rook captures
Bishop captures and now Queen to e do
with ideas of putting pressure on the h5
pawn either one of these nights is
coming to a5 at some point maybe rook to
h1 is an idea moving after the h5 pawn
but here ding again forces Magnus to
defend the bishop we have rook to a3 and
now Queen back to d3 dingos Bishop to c7
he at some point he maybe he's
interested in pushing at 5 maybe if pawn
captures than this
one can be pushed and then both the
bishop and queen are going after the g3
pawn and here are crossing goes Knight
e5 check we have nine chapters on e5
Knight captures on e5 with check and
here King to f8 here's the point that I
made a bit earlier if King h8 then
Queens to d1 is just super strong you
keep an eye on the bishop while also
attacking the h5 pawn the rook H 1 will
be deadly since the King is occupying
the H file
so after Knight h5 check we have Kingdom
f8 binding and here it's a very
interesting position but Magnus is still
down a pawn and he has to you know have
some compensation for it and it's very
interesting Bishop is controlling the f7
the knight controls these two squares so
you could try and threaten check mate
with a queen sacrifice after Luke d1 now
the threat is of course Queen d8 Bishop
captures Ruby eight mate
the problem is black defends against
this well with Bishop captures here and
after pawn captures you can just harass
the Queen the Queen has to keep an eye
on the bishop after the Queen moves now
push III and the Queen no longer defends
the g3 pawn the bishop and queen will
just win the game here your only defense
is to block with the rook but it's not
the same as before when we said that it
was possible here after Bishop capture C
captures h4 just wins wins on the spot
so after King to f8 cross and plate
Queen to c2 and now ding plate Queen to
g4 and here the blacks position is
excellent you're threatening a lot of
ideas some of them include or just look
at force on v3 and after the Queen moves
from the defense of d4 pawn maybe even
Queen captures on e4
you could also just capture the knight
push h4 a lot of excellent ideas here
for dink
so Magnus defensive with rook to f3 you
don't want to leave your g3 point
unguarded also you bring another
defender to the bishop here but this is
also a move that's really bad for Magnus
but feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the best move for ding
in this position well I have a nice leap
of my water
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have you are now
very close to beating world champion
Magnus Carlsen and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show Bishop e6 just
attack this do it one more time and
here's the problem
White has to make a move and there
really are no good moves for white white
just has to make a waiting move let's
say rookie 3 just as black is preparing
to capture here you do want to bring
another defender to d4 pawn but here
black just trades rook captures and now
you have to capture with the rook rook
captures rook after screen captures and
now you will capture here with check and
if white doesn't want to lose a piece
here you have to block with the Queen
and now black and just trade captures
captures King of 7 and you play the same
game where you are up two pawns you know
a bishop and a night we're up two pawns
should be should be more than winning
for black but they missed this didn't
play Bishop captures an f5 and now we
have looked at for some f5 by Magnus and
h4 and here yes it does seem like black
is breaking through but with the dark
square bishop being blocked by the e5
pawn oh not not so clear here cross
someplace that rook captures on f6 with
check clink the g7 but now look f7 check
just defending and now you don't want to
go to some silly squares as you know you
don't want to go here there's all sorts
of nasty discoveries become possible
then goes to g6 but now Queen to f2
threatened in Queen to f6
so here Bing doesn't have time to
capture the bishop here ding has the
trade Queens with Queen captures and g3
Queen captures and now H captures on g3
and now you could trade bishops but if
you trade but she was a bishop captures
rook captures rook captures on c6 check
King g5 its Carson doesn't like this
position as of course he there aren't a
lot of winning chances here for example
rook c8 you want to push her C pawn rook
c3 anything would put his room behind
the C pawn c6 you looking at for c7 now
we go rook C to check King F 1 and now
King captures on e4 and here Magnus is
just down upon and there's no way to
Queen this point so not something
Carlson is interested in and fairly
quickly he decides against it he just
plays Bishop to e6 ding of course
the guard his bishop as well we have
Bishop to d8 and now King to h3 and here
it's a thing is still up upon but the
problem is even after let's say Bishop
g5 to f4 guarding the g3 pawn you can
never go look to a2 to escort to the
pawn over the g2 square because Magnus
Bishop is controlling the a2 square
without this it would be most likely
already lost for for Carlsen
so Dean continues with the plan Bishop
to g5 but now rook the c7 Magnus goes
after the Queen side pawns with Bishop
to f4 and now rook captures on c6
threatening all sorts of discoveries
like Bishop c4 can win the pawn and here
again
ding misses a very nice opportunity of
playing rook to e7 and now Bishop c4
doesn't do anything since King g5 and
our white is white is in huge trouble
yeah you can play a lot of things like
just bring the rock over here deliver
cherry deliver check on h2 and there's
not a lot to go here for white so here
after rook captures on c6 ding played
King to g5 he decided he doesn't want
any of this discovery action and Magnus
just played Bishop to f7 preparing rook
to g6
and amazingly here Bishop to e3 is the
move ding has to play or E or even g2
just making room for for the better of
giving up the pawn but the ding played
Bishop to d2 and it's a move that loses
the game for ding but again feel free to
pause the video and try to find it this
idea that Magnus played will have a nice
last sip of my water for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just taken advantage of a
really nice blunder and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show room g6
it's actually move magnets prepared and
here is it's just lost if King h5 rook
g3 opens up for discovery and wins the
rook and a3 and if you play the move
ding played being played King F or again
Magnus just played King g4 check and it
was in this position that ding resigned
to the game because after you move the
King doesn't really matter where let's
say king of three Ruby g3 check King has
to capture again use the rook and it's
game over but interestingly after Bishop
to f7 we said that Bishop to e3 was fine
Bishop to d2 is not fine because
Bishop to e3 just blocks blocks any
attack towards the rook so ruby g6 check
would met with King a for now you can go
Ruby for check king of three but after
King captures here you will capture here
and there is no capturing of the rook so
it's very interesting that this game was
decided by the most active move with the
rook England you know kept playing the
entire game he just kept playing rock a3
after Magnus moved the Queen and then
Magnus brings the Queen back he goes
back but then again and now it kind of
cost him the game which is a very very
sad for for ding ha but yeah a very nice
game and now I will mention it it is of
course a Norma given game their
classical game was grunting was better
but Magnus was able to save it and then
of course King had his opportunity in
the Armageddon as well but Magnus just
just keeps on winning so here we do have
the standings here they are after after
this round let me just bring them down a
bit
Costin still in first place in the
autumn of straw a championship nine and
a half points 2nd place you young e with
8 points level are in the following with
seven and a half then with six and a
half Wesley so ding is now in fifth
place with five and a half sharing it
with a Vishwanathan Anand mama Dee are
off with five again sharing with Fabiano
Corwin Oh with five maxime beaugeois
four and a half and Alexander Lee shook
in last place with three will issue had
a terrible terrible misfortune in his
Armageddon game against Caruana today
he just blundered the bishop it's really
really a crazy position played Bishop to
h6 and Khurana just grabbed it he had a
finger on Bishop and on the previous
movie she blocked his Queen that was you
know just supposed to be protecting the
bishop but he blocked it with 92 and 92
and the Queen was no longer regarding
the bishop which was really really
insane but yeah it's just you know
things happen just amazing but really
really really bad for for Gration yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Austin wheeler for
contribute to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it
as usually come checked on my previous
video so you're thinking for watching
and I will see you soon
continuing covering
of course the other box with
championship changing up in your
suggestions as usual and of course after
the championship ends we are continuing
to the Capablanca saga thank you all I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your day